how's of guys my name is a general
welcome to episode 8 of the Sparky game
engine series so today we're going to be
talking about making a renderer last
time we created all of these beautiful
buffer kind of methods right and what
we'll do today is actually use them in a
renderer okay so to set up our round row
if I go back to last episode's drawing
board we had all of this cool stuff and
we talked about hammering works and we
talked about the fact that a renderer
will have will basically be responsible
for rendering renderable 2ds okay which
is these things which have all this
stuff like position size color and from
then on they will construct their own
vertex buffer index buffer color buffer
all that cool stuff
all right so to get that stuff to work
now we need to implement a renderer some
kind of render at the dozen so what
we'll do what our plan is here is to
basically implement this renderable 2d
which will be essentially a sprite is
some realization of that kind of
interface and that kind of I guess
superclass right and then our render a
2d which will have submit a flush so we
can submit readable two days and they
will get rendered and then submit we'll
put them into some kind of queue and it
will work like that so it should be
should be really good so let's get
started so on the graphics I'm going to
make a new item called renderable and
this will just be a header on the kind
of thing renderable 2d all right so this
is something that one thing I should
probably mention by the way is previous
episode when I was testing this I just
bound Ibo twice without actually
unbinding it so we should have probably
done that and actually one more thing I
want to mention quickly is that a lot
yeah we did all this cool stuff last
time I forgot to say that obviously with
being able to set colors per vertex like
we were doing we can do some pretty cool
stuff where we mix up oops where we mix
up say the colors and we can do some
pretty cool stuff where it you know does
as you can see that colors like more of
a gradient right so we could have done
some cool stuff like that I've ever
probably demonstrated it but I did not
so what I'm demonstrating it's now
so how's oops so how's this pretty cool
right
so anyway that being said back to our
renderable 2d pragma once so as we note
it out on our drawing board
we should have a submit and a flush
right in our renderer but in a turrible
we should have position size color we
probably won't worry about textures just
yet since we don't have textures yet and
we should have a vertex buffer near this
buffer probably a color buffer as well
right for those cars so let's get
started
we'll have our name space and I
explained all of this last episode by
the way so I explained probably more
last episode that I should have so
anyway so we wouldn't really have
private we'll just have projected things
we shouldn't really need private things
so protected will have so we'll need to
include our maths stuff so this will be
in I think just maths math right maths
yeah that's all right we'll also need to
have glued and this is just for the
reason of also another way by this I
meant to say we all need to have our
buffers so Buffett H index before H and
the vertex array okay so we've got all
this cool stuff so what we do need to
have is maths vector so size would be an
example I guess I'll just make this M
size we'll have a Mass Effect 3 position
and again it's a even though it's a
renderable today we're having a 3d
position just because off the Z value
which we want to use to control the
rendering order basically what's in
front of what we still want to be even
if we're 2d we still want to control
what is in front of water so that's what
that third water is for and then the
color
now we'll be just a vet for all right
cool
so we've got these are the actual things
we store but we also need to have a a
buffer called M color buffer we want to
have a buffer that is M vertex buffer we
want to have vertex array and vertex
array and we want to have index buffer m
index buffer so a lot of lot of crazy
stuff we've got here so so added this
stuff what needs to be constructed let's
see buffer does okay what we'll do is
we'll actually we'll actually have them
all on the M on the heap and I think
what we'll do is yeah so we don't
actually I don't think we actually need
vertex and color buffer because we're
just going to send them off into the
vertex array anyway so yeah we won't
have that so we'll just have a vertex
array in an index buffer okay so when we
actually create a renderable 2d só
renderable 2d this will probably be a
protected constructor as well so we'll
probably pass in something on lines of
so we'll need okay so we'll just say
Willie we need a position a position a
size and the color right and will
control this through sprite a bit
differently but in fact we can just say
effect for will just say vac for number
one does what sprite in fact we go okay
so sighs I know why I called it M
position position size and Karla all
right so this constructor apart from
just doing all this cool constructor II
stuff like this in fact I'll just do
that here I will just do them all in a
row sighs sighs m'kay la la la
okay so let's create a vertex so vertex
array is pretty simple to create an
index buffer will be basically the same
for everything week we could make this
static it's up to you whether or not you
want to will keep it not static now just
to prove a point but and that point
being the fact that these can have
different index buffers rather than
using one will probably do both actually
to be honest so this will be a GL
you short
in the seas okay
we'll pass it into season six into here
so renderable duties will have the same
kind of shape here um okay so we'll go
ahead and that looks pretty good to me I
think we've made pretty much everything
need to make you so we obviously want to
have methods such as Mack Mass Effect 3
from the concepts Factory get position
which will return and position will make
them all in line as well we might have
to force them to be in line but we won't
worry too much about optimization yet
this episode eight isn't it so episode
10 will be the maintenance /
optimization episode which we'll have to
talk about where we have size position
color okay cool
there we go so now we've basically made
this pretty good so at the moment you
can't change this stuff if you remove
Const you will be able to change this
stuff so it's not too difficult too
difficult to do that if you want to but
anyway anyway it should be good anyway
will if we do that if we do do that
stuff a lot of construction anyway that
way so I don't really want to do it that
way let's make sure that we do two
things
let's make sure we actually push the
vertices in one on but to create the
vertices for our vertex array we need to
go ahead and go GL float vertices equals
okay um let's see
so we basically want to go through
position so zero zero will be the first
vertex then we'll go ahead and say
position dot X which we will go in
clockwise won't we
so we'll just do zero position y zero
and then vision X and then position X 0
so that's our vertices done okay let's
also do our colors so we'll go color dot
X color dots why we probably need to
probably could give aliases to these and
say and make color dot RGB a as well so
in other words we could give we give
back for srgb a but we want to do that
now we could do that using say Union or
something by the way but anyway um there
we go everything's good in the hood now
that we've got these things we can go
ahead and say and vertex array dot add
buffer so the first thing we want to add
is probably a point of this right is if
we want to add a new buffer being the
vertex one so let's add in the vertices
and this account will be what is it well
it will be four times three the
component count will be three and what
we need
oh yeah and then here we need the index
okay and then we're adding the colors
four times three four times four four
and then one same is what we did in
Maine right and I explained that in
pretty good detail there I think anyway
so now that we've done all that we need
to definitely set up a destructor which
deletes the vertex array and oops m5x
array
what's Martha's virtual obviously and
index buffer that's it's yes okay cool
there we go so we've got a pretty good
renderable 2d class now that sets up all
this stuff
hopefully flawlessly and and it looks
pretty good in general I think I guess
we'll see okay cool so let's actually
make that sprite now so we'll make a new
item we'll make a actually know what we
don't need to really make a sprite right
now let's make the renderer let's make
the renderer so render a to detail CVP
and render a render to do page okay so
around ro 2 D is going to have so this
is going to be this is just going to be
a superclass so we're not going to do
stuff in here such as actually
implemented okay this will just be a
superclass because there'll be multiple
render two days that we'll do so we'll
have our namespace our namespace of
glory
that's this official name now namespace
of glory which visual studio keeps
trying to correct so render a 2d well
have the following things it will have
so it'll have a it'll probably all
almost almost all be protected but
really all it will do is it will have a
void submit which takes in a Ren
sorry a render rebel 2d okay and it will
have a wound at that and it will have a
flash so these are going to be pure
virtual methods which means that when we
actually extend this class will be
forced to implement it and also we won't
be able to actually instantiate this
class okay but that's the idea so it's
just something that gives us in chat
kind of so include renderable 2d all
right cool
that's the idea I'm not sure if I
actually want to taking pointers here as
in if I want to take in year mmm I guess
so I mean let's just think quickly do I
want to have reference
submit let's think
mmm I don't think so I think I'll just
take in Const references okay that
should be pretty good anyway this is our
render 2d so we don't actually need a
Seabee be called out we'll rename the
CVP to be called simple 2d renderer okay
and then we will steal that file name
and then we'll make a dot H file for it
how to file for it okay so anyway let's
copy and paste this quickly
so this will and then into renderer
today I'll also include other stuff we
may need such as OpenGL and our maths
library okay so let's go ahead and
that's all good
so let's include our renderer no not
that render plots I'll show you our
simple renderer which is this so in here
I'll include renderer 2d okay and then
this will be simple 2d renderer so
inside here we'll have a few things
first of all we'll have a queue so the
queue implementation were probably going
to use is a double ended queue so double
n is here just like that
okay so we'll make that here DQ and it
will be a queue of Const renderable
references of course so conce renderable
so i renderable 2d and we'll call this
render or m render queue okay we'll have
a these businesses these methods will be
public we should probably make the other
ones public but whatever if we mark them
as override it will correct us if we're
wrong so that's nice so in this case we
need to make it
all right and then supply will be
right okay so we need obviously derive
from our renderer 2d okay so there we go
now we're overriding them properly let's
have a winner lose really need to have a
constructor I don't think really all all
of this this is going to be quite a
simple class right if we just grab these
things this is going to be as I said
quite a simple renderer but really all
we're doing is when we implement the
stuff in our simple 2d renderer why
don't you get rid of that okay when we
doing stuff like this let's take a
little what this is doing literally all
this is doing right now is it's hitting
up and render queue dot
pushback right renderable okay that's
all that is doing and then when we come
on to flash that's where the magic
begins so really again this is called a
temple 2d renderer because it is a
simple 2d renderer all it's going to do
is going to basically say while our M
render queue right MT is false so as
long as the queue is not empty then what
we need to do is basically call let's
just say renderable - so conce trainable
to dereference renderable is going to
equal m render queue dot France okay so
we've got the reference we're going to
we're going to go ahead and go
renderable dot okay so this is a at this
point we need to actually grab all the
stuff I think I forgot to add most of
all the stuff that we needed so we've
got to get position but we don't
actually have these vertex round buffers
so let's make an inline
and I guess const vertex array gets vio
ash will return and vertex array make
sure it's a pointer and then IBO get
index buffer object which will force
returning in index life a pointer M
index buffer okay cool so back here now
we want to go ahead and call renderable
dot get V work with me get okay why you
why you sad get VAR binds ah this is
just so sad inaccessible oh well that's
probably my fault yes it is so let's
make this stuff public okay back here
okay so we're binding it let's not
forget to unbind it this is what flash
does so it's going to draw everything
step by step it's going to bind it it's
going to bind be renderable get IBO and
unbind it AB and one of thumb okay and
then it's going to basically go ahead
and say jail draw elements
let's see so jail triangles count is
going to be renderable dot get IBO get
counts type is going to be GL unsigned
shorts and then zero because we're not
zero or null pointer or whatever you
want to pass in there because we're not
actually what I'm actually going to
quickly specify in the indices they get
bound instead cool so this is perfect
except for the fact that it doesn't
actually address our like Crusaders it
doesn't address our current position so
what it needs to do is probably get the
current shader that we're trying to use
and and bind it and use it to position
the actual object so in other words we
bind the shader outside of this bit
needs to actually push to the current
shader preferably the the like our
position because right now this is
remember this is all of our size stuff
if we go back to our vulnerable 2d you
can see that the way that it calculates
size and whatnot is using this model
matrix that it does where are my red
apple 2d right so yeah so we've got a
we've got this position but you can see
we don't actually use position anywhere
I'm an idiot sorry I meant to do size
here we're not actually using position
anywhere right because we're going from
0 0 if we wanted to we could have just
done say position dot y plus size Y done
this for all of the other things and
then that would work but remember I want
to be able to move these around freely
so I don't really want to do that so at
this point we've got two options we
could either make a shader inside here
and then simply grab that shader and use
that or whatever or we could just do it
to the current shader for example so
there's a lot of stuff we could do I
think I'm just going to do it at the
current shader or something like that so
aura shader we pass into flash there's
just so many different ways we could do
this so I think what we could do though
if we were really nice it's probably do
something along the lines of this will
be better actually
so shader shader will call this am
shader okay so this shader which will
have to include graphics already in
graphics so just shader when we do this
we'll make a I guess we'll just specify
a shader as well this is going to be a
it's not gonna be Const okay so Shanna
chata and then well so this isn't a
shader that we actually manage so I
think we'll probably just make this a
reference to a shader so M shader shader
okay so this is not a this is not a
shader that we manage ourselves this is
something that we include from the other
thing and it will just totally handle it
for us and then of course we want to
take a chatter as well so in line not
const shader get shader which will be
const and return m shader okay cool so
now in our simple 2d renderer dot CBP we
can go ahead and say based on the size
we can go ahead and say we could keep
this as a may so many different ways to
do this we could say renderable dot get
shader write dots sets uniform mass for
so at this point we could just say we
want to set the model matrix to maths
mat for translation and then render i
think i'll just do it this way so in
this case we're reconstructing the
matrix every frame probably not the best
thing to do but you know whatever
renderable dot get position alright so
we can do something like that
that's totally legit and then that will
actually set the model matrix to be
whatever our thing is and that looks
pretty good that's actually legitimately
it that's all we need to do so it's
pretty simple that's why it's called a
simple 2d renderer but it should get the
job done pretty
well except again again we need one draw
call per renderable which is a bit mmm
but that's okay so let's go ahead and
make that did I make the constructor
private or protect it or something I
think I did
let's don't do that so then renderable
let's make this in fact I think
everything should be public yeah so what
does make this public and we'll get rid
of this this public here so back out
here right now what are we doing we're
doing all this stuff I'm going to just
delete pretty much all of this because
we don't really need it anymore I might
keep it here just for reference because
I kind of want to do the same thing
don't I
hmm and then all this mess I'll just get
rid of okay so what I'll do here is up
top I'll go ahead and create so what do
we want we want two things right we want
graphics we want a renderer 2d and then
we want to render a bull 2d so go ahead
and say over here for example create a
renderable 2d we'll call this our
sprites for example so what do we need
for this which you would help me um we
need a position so we'll say maybe zero
zero zero we'll do something more fun
five five zero then we need a the size
of this so the size will be like what
was the other side stuff that we had I
was like eight ish four will make it 4
so 4 4 4 for example the color will be
pink why not College testings and then
the shader will be the shader so we
don't actually have one yet but it's
going to be this all right cool
so there's our sprite so if we want to
render the sprite now let's construct
the renderer render a 2d so yeah you can
just go render a 2d renderer and then
we'll look at that we'll go simple
around simple to the renderer which is
an implementation renderable which is an
implement Oh back you go up up so simple
to your renderer renderer and then we'll
just call render adult submit our
glorious sprite and render a dot flush
yeah so let's see this is a moment truth
let's see if it works
ill there is okay so what up pointer to
reference is illegal what's going on
well this is mean point of reference is
legal or does it not want us to use
references I think it might not want us
to use references okay we use pointers
them let's go back to our simple 2d
renderer so we'll make a queue of
competent normal references of Const 2d
point is then I guess and then out here
we'll do the same thing so we'll take in
or yeah we'll push that in we'll have to
go back here and make this totally
acceptable and then
I'll have to make this a pointer and
then we'll have to change all this stuff
to be this alright you're happy now so
now we'll have to you okay
submit has no okay yeah so let's go back
to renderer change that to that and then
when do we submit it let's submit it
like that I guess okay it's happier
Tapia but we're also not responding so
that's also great that's probably
because we're not removing it from our
queue are we I think I forgot to do that
I did so once we do all this stuff once
we do go render queued up front you have
to make sure that we actually pop the
front of out of our queue okay otherwise
whenever removing elements for it and
this while will be just completely
completely good so there we go so it
looks like it's working we're probably
at about five five right so it looks
pretty good so that's one sprite and
it's pink so that's all totally the best
it seems so let's create more than just
one sprite let's go ahead and so we're
our sprite so that's one sprite that
we've got let's create another sprite at
1 comma at five point one or seven color
one and we'll make it a bit smaller and
bit wider maybe or patola and we'll make
it some other color like maybe let's
make it like let's make it kind of
blueish like that right let's call it
sprite - and then let's actually submit
it
what did we oh yeah
okay let's let's get rid of all this
stuff because we don't we know love it
need it now much better much more
breathing room look at our sprite in
sprite - cool so it seems to work pretty
well I'd say that light is pink which is
a bit weird but I'm not going to look
too much into that because I'm sure
that's something strip without lighting
calculation anyway this looks pretty
good and it looks like everything is
working fairly well so there we go
so now we've got a simple 2d renderer so
we just submit things to it and it does
its work so if you guys have any
questions about that leave a comment
below anything else I wanted to mention
I think so so yeah um next time we will
next time what we will will move on to a
more complicated renderer probably that
does things we might clean a few things
up in this render a first but will
probably move on to more complicated
things and and yeah so if you guys enjoy
this video please hit like button and
I'll see you guys next time goodbye
you